from the network that redefined
television with shows like The Sopranos
Deadwood and the wire comes this don't
answer Entourage oh yeah
HBO already hit it vid with four
self-absorbed women treating New York
City like their personal sex playground
now get ready for the exact same thing
with dudes in Los Angeles
but not just any away Doug Ellen's
fantasy version of la full of boobs
butts Bay's bros brunch bogs and no
black people seriously almost everyone
in the city is white except for Lloyd
he's cute right and he covers two quotas
leave Vinny a movie star with no talent
no charisma and by some miracle no
herpes along for the ride is his posse
of childhood friends
E thus marking know-it-all who's the
least fun part of every episode fiercer
violence car you can spend $320,000 on a
car turtle your average entourage fan
drama the underappreciated brother of a
more famous sibling kind of like Kevin
Dillon and Ari Gold a sexist that's why
no more guys to fire a guy you create a
rival you fire a woman you create a
housewife racist speak or I will intern
you like it's 1942 I am NOT Japanese Ari
speak homophobe has so much been
supported in those eyes you can't see
what's right in front of your face who's
such an awful person being a talent
agent is the fifth worst thing about him
really
in a business where every actors career
is a roller coaster of highs and lows
follow Vinnie and the boys on a
consequence-free journey from highs to
even higher highs full of non crises
like will Vince get to can on time I
guess I'm going to catch will a blackout
keep Vince's movie from breaking
box-office records the biggest thing the
blackout's affected were the actual
reporting of the numbers did turtle and
dramas wieners touch we accidentally
crossed swords ill well anvil fans have
to donate more money to Matt Damon's
charity before flying to Italy on his
private jet call Marvin Haim write a
check for hundred fifty grand and Matt's
charity okay get ready to say hey I know
that guy
as she watching unending parade of
celebrity cameos featuring celebrities
playing themselves hey Peter Jackson hey
it's Martin Scorsese
Stan Lee hi celebrities not famous
enough to play themselves people who are
never that famous in the first place
people who become way more famous than
anyone on the show ever thought you know
the station agent yeah it's about the
[ __ ] who lives by the train tracks
last time I saw him he was in a FedEx
commercial they were overnighting him to
London
his name is Peter Dinklage ari awkward
flip your hat back and pop your collar
as you witness the height of Bro culture
where gays are gross girlfriends are for
[ __ ] and chicks are either
ballbusting shrews Ari Gold's balls are
being held by or bangable flesh trophies
mean is when I made just Mancini ride
her bike home at the right head dude
really so raise your glass and settle in
for the TV version of booze where a
little bit is fine but too much at once
will make you want to punch somebody
you then get depressed and cry yourself
to sleep how many people does it take to
handle one talentless actor story weed
shots chicks two chicks at the same time
sick cars private jets growing out hug
it out Lloyd's
boy boy Eric and Sloan breaking up so I
are taking a break I want to get back
together that will never happen
Eric and Sloan getting back together Wow
E on tequila tequila Avion IV I IV I VI
IV oh man phone calls hey Ari what's up
yo E
what's up what's up Lloyd hey hey drama
what's up hey what's up turtle hey
what's up turtle drama hey Ari what's up
sup Lord outdated cultural references oh
this broad I met on myspace she's coming
hey how come you're not on this Facebook
thing ah because I'm an adult it's the G
Lee effect Wow Vince isn't doing the
movie I don't want to do Aquaman Vince
is doing the movie I'd like to come play
Aquaman formants sure and toast glasses
up
to Saigon top family be together
yes my getting a job in some food the
real douche bags are overly hills
say what you will about the entourage
would be but I totally see James
Cameron's Aquaman Aquaman to last you be
sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers hey screen junkies if you love
movies
please visit our friends at film
theorists the new channel from the minds
behind game theory check them out and
tell him scream junkie sent you be sure
to subscribe
oh wait I already said that something in
the style of Chewbacca
shomer Shabbos these are my adventure
pans for adventures and my pans so long
and thanks for all the fish